je suis enceinte tu lui en à parlé vrai
qu'est ce que tu vas faire
je crois que je vais revoir
ils sont programmés pour ne pas en être
capable
[Applaudissements]
inquiet
[Musique]
après le blitz on a attendu ailleurs
pendant quelques mois on a un truc
à tous vous deviendrez normal
kouchner
non c'est juste que j'ai mal
tu pourrais avoir de bébé aujourd'hui
coup dans une semaine samedi à rien
d'attendre bord du no man's land en
espérant que personne ne trouve
jeu du ray pour te sauver je pourrais
mourir pour toi
je ferai pareil pour notre bébé
vous aviez à boston c'est ça je peux
t'en mener la barque
sans aucun danger
l'amour noro égoïste
et
l'amour ne tuera tous
[Musique]